all right so good my name's Davey United
can you read here it's a brooch if it
could be predicted ferny
my name is Vanessa my fort is so big oh
[Music]
[ __ ]
guess where I'm at [ __ ] I'm at
my favorite brunch spot on earth not
just brunch my friends burger specialty
but today I wanted to feature this place
because I've been coming here I say at
least three to four times a week
[ __ ] my wrists that for my cartwheel now
they have a something here that I are
really like and it's their spam and egg
sandwich now I know what you're thinking
span an egg sandwich David who eats that
type of [ __ ] but it's not just the spam
and egg sandwich this place does
something very very special in a place
that's dear to my heart
so let's go inside and talk about the
food that we're gonna drop on now I'll
feed you this place multiple times
[ __ ] this bus man you're gonna
understand why it's so damn delicious
welcome my friends this right here is
that delectable treat that I've been
talking about now I'm not just eating
this place just because like it's just a
spot that I walk by every time I
genuinely think that this is one of the
breakfast
burger spots that you could ever go to
an the reason wife because they have a
very small menu and they specialize in
what they do really here and that's the
type of spots that I like I don't like
places with 4,000 things on the menu
unless it's like Zippy's from Hawaii
which is you know you know that's that
[ __ ] right here cousin going up I spam a
lot it was like spam aids and rice and
it's literally I'm trying to do a video
and I haven't looked in a mirror and
agents were you call an ugly [ __ ] going
up as I'm kid I hate a lot of spam and
haze like spam eggs rice was like this
[ __ ] almost like every Asian family cool
up eating that but here they actually
make their spam in-house is a completely
different experience I'm talking about
it's all crispy on the edges it has like
this corned beef hash type of taste to
it but the crunch of bacon which I
really enjoy it this buttery delicious
scrambled egg right there and guess what
this delicious like brioche bun see that
little push in that bounce that you get
from it it's made in house so she who's
actually a co-owner of this place bakes
all this [ __ ] here proves the bread
bakes it in their cute little ass
kitchen and you be amazed what they can
do in that small space and I'm gonna
show you what's up cousin and what I
personally like to eat with this is a
little hot sauce this is a very decadent
it's very rich and you're gonna think
that you know I could probably eat a
couple of these but most likely you
won't just because it's so rich and I
need that hot sauce to get that little
Tapatio flavor on it like that
this is like the perfect breakfast
sandwich today I don't want any other
vegetable [ __ ] I don't know why with
breakfast I don't want like veggies and
also the [ __ ] I just want something just
like stick in your gut
stick-to-your-ribs delicious then you
have this pillowy [ __ ] bomb-ass
brioche bun that garlic aioli and the
eggs are always fresh and plain [ __ ]
love this thing if you come here and you
don't get this you must look up Oh
the presentation is just in the
sandwiches so it's not gonna like extra
frills but only right now come here get
the [ __ ] that you love spam and eggs and
you like that delicious sweet eggy
breath to go with it you're gonna want
the sandwich I'm gonna take one more
bite
let me bless it real quick
Tapatio sponsor me what's up
well okay well I want you to start out
since you know what you're doing so well
all right what's up everybody
we're here at Target to get waxed to
wash my armpits cos it's so hairy you
live it up
is everybody all right no you are all
left first of all I want to thank target
for sponsoring us hashtag ad I like the
fact that you guys are venturing out and
sponsoring pieces of [ __ ] like me yeah
do you want to stock up on some extra
smalls hello yes good to
mom you're embarrassing me aren't we you
get well now I'm a little self-conscious
target is sponsoring me see I like the
poor sponsorships even if you don't want
me to support your brand I'm gonna do it
anyways yeah I represent your company
now think about that so if you have a
target app you just log in use the
barcode to find discounts and then you
just scan it and there's no discount but
if it had one so Sally Hansen is also
sponsoring this video
you guys can't you want I know that a
lot of people out there think that
family-friendly branding is the best way
to go and it's actually not because most
people in this world are pieces of [ __ ]
and they also buy things too
my fans are great we'll see how once the
eyes unit if you want to do your whole
leg dude you're gonna be I will see how
painful it is first it's not that bad I
think I don't do my legs oh did you do
they'll be slipping out of your bed so
you just wanna do a bunch of strips and
just do it how long does it take for
Lake hair to grow back for me to get my
manhood back you never get your man oh
[Music]
that one's [ __ ] hurt you [ __ ] cut
ass clean [ __ ]
okay Mariah
what's next Vanessa so now we're gonna
show you his armpit hairs so we can wax
the [ __ ] off because tool hour like I
like going to experience just like this
because now I get to understand what it
takes for a women to live to a certain
level of beauty bro
I [ __ ] hate you like you just lean
that way I don't let
[Music]
okay okay
oh it is bleeding it's bleeding isn't it
I smell the blood we gotta clean up to
be sticky okay you're such a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] no sorry
could you rip out the frickin follicle
dude there's no
yay nice you talk really longer legs I
think I like these best four legs not
for anything else yeah Sally Hansen four
legs only don't use this on your vagina
are you talking [ __ ] about a homey dish
bread no be human I don't think you know
what you I could do you Budokan you I
see this booklet
how many Billy's view having your teeth
as you laugh I saw all the [ __ ]
fillies in your mouth
oh damn [ __ ] I got it watch
Oh doubt that you want the other way oh
you get the okay look at the camera
begin how are you doing Monroe
okay get it okay okay I got it
or a bit sweaty again it's okay cuz of
the beer all the way to our [ __ ] arms
the heat on there you know sainthood
what's a good song that we could sing
what's a good song a Spice Girls are you
really good at
yes I know what you want what you really
want